>>Beth A. Brooke: I just came out of the Denver
parody group and we had a fabulous discussion;
made several commitments and I know our organization
Ernst & Young is very committed to continuing
to promote the business case for the inclusiveness
of women and people of different ethnicities,
sexual orientation. But the purpose of all
of that, is to have a diverse set of perspectives
around the table. Frankly, at this point in
time with the financial crisis, if you have
and you actually have a diverse organization,
which we do, and you empower the use of that
diversity to tackle issues, tackle challenges,
to create innovative ways to address the challenges
that we face we think that we'll get better
answers.
That was one of the recommendations coming
out of the gender parody group. We're committed
to it and I know the other members of the
gender parody group are. So I'm delighted.
I just hope we get more organizations truly
embracing the value of diversity, inclusiveness
and how it can produce tangibly different
outcomes for the future.